here's what would happen if a gamma-ray  burst hit a black hole black holes and  gamma rays already interact pretty often  a black hole releases a burst of  gamma-ray light when it's created if you  were near the explosion gamma rays would  pass through your body they'd deliver an  extremely high dosage of radiation you'd  suffer radiation sickness you'd become  nauseous lose your hair and even bleed  this Collision would result in a  beautiful explosion one billion trillion  times brighter than the sun sadly you  won't be able to see it some light  photons have the right amount of  frequency to be visible to your eyes but  the frequency of gamma rays is way too  high your eyes aren't Advanced enough to  see their beautiful bursts so until our  sun collapses into a black hole and  sends a burst of gamma rays in your  direction you don't have to worry but